[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24 y
más Romero sala está con nosotros en el
estudio mar bienvenida buena mañana de
jueves Ya dejamos atrás los análisis de
los Nobel para enfocarnos entonces en
nuestra sección de salud nos vamos a
timar porque apareció un brote de cólera
Después de tres años sin tener casos de
esta enfermedad y nos trae pues
dolorosos recuerdos Sí exactamente Es
una noticia dolorosa la que nos ha
traído octubre en este país además
reiteradamente olvidado no en el
Continente Americano el 2 de octubre
daban este anuncio las autoridades del
Ministerio de salud de Haití
según toda la información que tenemos el
número de muertes va de 7 a 8 una muerte
sucedió durante el día de hoy
desafortunadamente y era una persona que
murió en la comunidad esto es un
problema que haya gente que tenga
diarrea vómitos y que no tenga forma de
llegar a los centros de salud donde
podrían sobrevivir los casos están
localizados sobre todo en dos zonas
concretas que están súper pobladas Y que
además sufren de especial pobreza en una
isla que ya tiene crisis económica desde
hace tiempo y que además al menos una de
ellas sobre todo está controlada por una
de las bandas armadas que actualmente en
Haití operan controlan pedazos de
territorio y que de hecho es una de las
razones también detrás de las que pues
el país está atravesando todas estas
múltiples crisis desde hace años no De
hecho actualmente hay protestas contra
el gobierno como estamos viendo en estas
imágenes durante la última semana
especialmente porque hay una escasez de
combustible y de hecho una de estas
bandas armadas está controlando el
acceso al poco suministro de gasolina
que hay esto provoca por ejemplo que
desde hace semanas haya hospitales haya
centros de salud que no están pudiendo
abrir sus puertas que no están pudiendo
recibir a pacientes también le pasa con
el acceso a agua limpia agua potable de
hecho el domingo una empresa
embotelladora de Haití tuvo que decir
que no podía seguir trabajando porque no
tenía combustible además de los
problemas de movilidad que suponen a
todos estos por todos estos factores que
estamos diciendo no todo esto no solo
dificulta enormemente la llegada de
pacientes que pueden estar infectados de
cólera que pueden estar enfermos a
recibir atención sanitaria sino que de
hecho pueden ser unas de las
explicaciones que pues que nos digan por
qué ahora el cólera ha reaparecido
Después de tres años Qué se puede hacer
mal ante un brote como como el que
podríamos enfrentar no como el que
estamos viendo sobre todo lo principal
es asegurar acceso tanto a servicios de
salud por supuesto como a medidas
higiénicas y agua limpia Esa es la
verdadera en línea de contención contra
es una enfermedad relativamente fácil de
tratar y de contener pero pues con estos
problemas no no Además es un virus
recordemos lo que se contagia cuando
bebes agua que ha estado contaminada por
los desechos por ejemplo de otra persona
que estaba enferma por eso esa
importancia de pues del agua limpia de
las medidas de higiene pero también hay
otros recursos y es el de las vacunas no
hay vacunas disponibles en el fondo
internacional de Gaby de la OMS como
hemos visto con otras enfermedades hemos
revisado hoy las cifras hemos visto que
los países de alrededor del mundo han
pedido casi 34 millones de dosis de
vacunas solo en lo que vamos de 2022 y
se han enviado un poco más de 16
millones Eso significa 8 millones de
personas inmunizadas más o menos porque
se requieren dos dosis Pues por cada
vacuna por cada esquema de vacunación
completa Sin embargo otra cosa que es
importante es que el tiempo de entrega
desde que se hace la solicitud hasta que
llegan estas vacunas es de 22 días
Entonces eso no es una particular buena
noticia en el caso de Haití en el caso
de que pues pida estas vacunas en días
en 22 días de tiempo medio de entrega
pues la enfermedad del brote podría
estar totalmente descontrolado Sabiendo
además que las cifras que tenemos
actuales de estas siete ocho muertes
podrían estar infra representadas mar y
lamentablemente no es la primera vez que
el cole era afecta Haití No recordemos
el dramático brote que hubo en 2010 y
dramático por muchas cosas tanto por su
magnitud como por realmente su historia
no este brote empezó en una pequeña
localidad que se llamaba Miguel justo
ahí había donde ven enmarcado en el mapa
había un campamento de cascos azules de
la ONU que venían del nepal donde el
cólera es endémico venían contagiados y
por errores y negligencias de gestión de
residuos pues se terminaron contaminando
el río que ven marcado en azul ese río
Pues que se llama arte boniti que va
pues transcurriendo hacia el Noroeste en
Haití y a los pocos días de que eso
sucediera ser yo como poco a poco las
comunidades que vivían río abajo desde
este punto se iban enfermando de cólera
el brote provocó hasta casi 10 muertes
820.000 contagios a lo largo de varios
años no duró hasta el 2019 son nueve
años de lucha contra una enfermedad que
además antes no existían Haití fue la
primera vez que se declaró un brote de
cólera ahí pero es que quizás lo pierde
esa historia fue la respuesta de la ONU
precisamente a eso no el organismo
internacional que está por supuestamente
debe velar por los derechos de todo se
lavó las manos constantemente durante
años de esta responsabilidad incluidos
expertos científicos de paneles que
decían que no estaba claro Pues en lo
que el origen del brote científicamente
hubiera sido el campamento azul pero
después en 2016 se hizo un informe
independiente también en la ONU Aquí les
damos un extracto en el que vemos no
cómo se denuncia que constantemente se
rechazará la responsabilidad las
peticiones los litigios de las mismas
víctimas la publicación de este informe
terminó en una disculpa de banki Moon
que era secretario general en ese
momento en el 2016 pero nunca hubo
ningún acto de responsabilidad o de
reparación hacia las víctimas de con un
país que ya está azotado por múltiples
crisis desde hace años porque reaparece
esta enfermedad claro De hecho se estaba
valorando declarar a ti libre de cólera
porque ya llevamos como decíamos hace
años desde 2019 claramente eso no se
puede decir es importante también decir
que el cólera se puede pues contagiar
siendo asintomático la mayoría de las
personas que se contagian de cólera o no
tienen síntomas o tienen leves síntomas
gastrointestinales perdón y además el
virus puede seguir pues viviendo en
aguas en otras zonas El problema es que
cuando las personas vuelven a entrar en
contacto con estas aguas contaminadas
pues vuelve a empezar toda la cadena de
hecho la Organización Mundial de la
Salud ayer estaba alertando de este
resurgimiento que ha habido del cólera
en varios lugares también en Siria de
hecho han habido varios casos que se han
detectado la alerta en Pakistán a raíz
de las recientes inundaciones que hubo
allí y pues recordamos las palabras de
la OMS no advertían que el cólera se
nutre de la pobreza de los conflictos y
también recientemente del cambio
climático es decir Podemos esperar que
sigan cada vez más casos y cada vez más
brotes ojalá que no Ojalá Muchísimas
gracias como siempre por toda la
información mañana con más salud mañana
con más